all right let's move on now to some more
Grammy gyms and that benefit brush off
that everybody
still talking about
all right Ben was feeling tired and
wasn't his usual self that's what we're
told is the real reason behind all the
sad Affleck faces our source adds Jen
knows Ben is a great husband but also
gets that bin as more of a homebody and
it isn't his thing to be out at events
all the time
so what did JLo say In This Moment
something she's giving him a scolding
saying sit up straight play it back and
that's possible we got a lip reader to
help us all out
stop look more friendly and then look
motivate it men allegedly responds I
might I mean all these miserable Affleck
faces and memes have lit up social media
then cut to the one moment he looked
happy inside with fellow actor Adrian
Brody many wondered if there's trouble
for benefit JLo's response to the
headlines she captioned her Grammy recap
always the best time with my love
and we have news on the couple's next
project together remember this Ben
working at The Duncan drive-thru E.T has
learned it has now become a Super Bowl
commercial and Jen makes a cameo
Harry how is it to perform at the
Grammys how much fun it was magical and
remember this moment during Harry Styles
Grammy performance it was actually
our turntable started spinning in
Reverse backward freaking all of us out
on live television that's Harry possibly
trying to alert stage texts before
nearly falling
when he nearly tripped my heart just
just talked 78 year old Harry superfan
Rena and her granddaughter without
Cassie Delora today showing off the
merch Harry gifted her and reliving how
the dream started we had no idea it had
anything to do with the Grammys we just
knew it was for a special TV project
we're gonna see Harry Styles in person
okay when that thought registered
through your mind what was your reaction
Panic
total panic Harry Styles
if he ever wants to get rid of me I
don't know I was going to do that
breaking the record now to more Grammy
controversy did you see this moment some
fans think Diplo was caught Throwing
Shade at Queen B after she beat him yep
we have some more lip reading they
bought that that's just one Fan's take
but our expert's verdict
well back on the carpet ET got some
movie sequel Scoops starting with a 90s
reboot a white man can't jump what can
you tell me it's good I'll tell you that
yeah yeah I've seen I've seen a good
amount of it now Spike Lee is our
greatest living director Ike Lee's not
even a good Knicks fan I knew this was a
mistake my first one I was nervous so
I'm like oh I hope it's good how about
girls trip two we're going to Ghana
y'all
yeah
supposedly I can't wait to find out when
I know it's gonna happen I just don't
know when where how all that stuff
Mamma Mia 3. I know you guys are
reducers on it are we getting it is it
happening you just have to wait and see
I can say this there's always room for
more joy in the world
and Ava's nominated tonight so maybe
it's all part of a theme
[Music]
thank you